a preguntarle en primer lugar qué hechos
registraron para concluir que rusia
cometió crímenes de guerra en ucrania
bueno muchas gracias santiago por el
espacio y en los últimos semanas verdad
amistad internacional me ha venido
documentando
este ataque de rusia el grave a hemos
podido recibir a través de diferentes
medios de vivencia medio gráfica que
hemos podido analizar a través de
nuestros expertos tanto en armas como en
imágenes satelitales y hemos podido
destacar que efectivamente ha habido
ataques indiscriminados en contra de
personas civiles en contra de espacios
que están protegidos por el derecho
internacional como son hospitales
escuelas se ha hecho un uso
indiscriminado de armas que no son de
precisión por tanto ponen en riesgo la
vida de personas en zonas altamente
pobladas es claro que hay una
intencionalidad de ataque en contra de
las personas civiles como un mecanismo
de castigo precisamente en el contexto
de este conflicto erika también se le
reprocha no al consejo de seguridad de
naciones unidas no actuar adecuadamente
frente a las atrocidades que se cometen
en ucrania no sólo en ucrania sino
también en otros países mencionan amar a
etiopía como cree que debería actuar el
organismo que debería cambiar
bueno si algo ha quedado claro en este
informe que estamos presentando sobre la
situación de derechos humanos en todo el
mundo es que van a hacer es que la
apuesta por los estados al mutilar
multilateralismo ha fracasado y
particularmente el consejo de seguridad
de naciones unidas se ha paralizado en
esfuerzos por atender las graves crisis
que se están dando en todo el mundo en
países como yemen del mar en silla en
etiopía y hoy día lo vemos igualmente en
el caso de lucrar ya donde ciertos
miembros del consejo de seguridad pues
terminan paralizando los esfuerzos por
atender los conflictos y estos miembros
pues pierden total legitimidad de
credibilidad porque muchos de ellos son
los perpetradores de esta violencia
ahora el informe también apunta contra
la desigualdad mundial no en lo que es
el acceso a la vacuna contra el cob y 19
y el recorte de derechos y libertades
bajo la cobertura de medidas sanitarias
a más de dos años del estallido de la
pandemia erika que esperanza hay para
las regiones más rezagadas en el acceso
a las vacunas
bueno los estados han fracasado en su
promesa de una recuperación justa tras
la pandemia o en el contexto de la
pandemia se han exacerbado las
desigualdades pero también hoy día los
gobiernos tienen una oportunidad de
poner los derechos humanos en el centro
estamos viendo múltiples movimientos de
protesta en todo el mundo que en vez de
ser recibidos con diálogo por parte de
las autoridades han sido recibidos con
represión pero son estos movimientos los
que están marcando la esperanza nos
están marcando una luz en este camino en
canarias